[Musique]
bienvenue ici sous un chapiteau mais
sous le chapiteau où va se jouer une
comédie musicale qui s'intitule padam
padam à partir de samedi jusqu'à
mercredi 27 octobre
c'est une cocréation que nous avons
écrit nous même pendant les différents
confinement c'est une pièce autour de
edith piaf avec une dizaine de chansons
de chansons françaises de chansons aussi
en anglais
ce que vous allez pouvoir découvrir par
exemple dans ce spectacle il ya un
medley des valses avec plusieurs valse
des chansons écrites par edith piaf ou
de son des chansons contemporaines à son
époque et donc c'est nous avons
chorégraphié smedley tout en couleur et
donc vous allez pouvoir découvrir cette
partie du spectacle qui est vraiment
magique féerique sous ce chapiteau
on a beaucoup de place sous chapiteau on
a 300 places et on a dix représentations
ici à versailles donc si on fait le
calcul dix représentations 300
spectateurs on peut aller jusqu'à 3000
personnes
[Musique]